We're gonna be talking about the, um,
Amon Arbery updates as well as we're gonna be reacting to, uh, co noir.
If you aren't aware, is that how you say his name? I don't know. You don't know?
Aren't you guys supposed to go shooting together? Yeah,
but I don't know how to say his name. You never said his name. I say call.
Like I write when you guys wait, when you guys don't talk, I write it. Yeah.
But when you talk to him, he doesn't be like, I don't my name saying my name.
No, that's never happened. Never. He's never like bust out a Destiny's child.
Why would he do that? Do you bust out dancing queen?
When we talk about your name? No,
but other people do fair, which is really annoying. Oh yeah.
Dancing. We speak French.
So the way we would say it in French would be
no <laugh> Ko lion, Nori, Nori.
When you multi is rough to some times read some things because people think
they disregard. <laugh> how things sound in their language. Yeah. And they just,
I would say his name coun. Okay. And I would just say coun,
but it doesn't matter. He made an update video.
So first we're gonna react to that. And then we'll go in my.
Original video about the Amma Aubrey shooting.
I said that Arbery didn't do anything wrong.
And that he was just out for a jaw a couple of days ago,
surveillance footage showing Amad Arbery walking inside a house that was under
construction was released onto the interwebs. Since this video's released,
I've been hounded by comments telling me to take my video down that I should
have waited for the facts. I'm a race Baer. I look stupid. He broke the law,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So since the release of this videos have my opinion changed. Well,
let's find out.
This surveillance video obtained by our Atlanta affiliate.
WSB will certainly be part of the debate.
It was recorded shortly before Arbery was killed and shows a man walking into an
open home construction site and looking around Arbery's family attorneys
say they believe this second video obtained by ABC news does show the 25 year
old, former football player in that home under construction.
But they underline that he wasn't breaking the law and left empty handed and
they are praying for them.
The family says they have no relat with the McMichael and would have never
wanted what they call a vigilante response.
Okay. Before I continue preach,
have you ever walked into an abandoned home or abandoned building? Yes. I have.
Why? When I was a kid, it was a police.
Like it was in development, you know what I mean? They were,
they were building and stuff like that. So it's like
two, three years. It was fields.
And then one day there's like a house in construction to bubble up.
Like I used to go there and play the fields. And now as a house, it's just,
you're a kid and you're like, whoa. It's like, you built that in a week.
And then you just interested in to see, I see my house was a new construction.
So I was like, okay, let me just see it's crazy.
It's just building this man can build this in such a little time.
So I was like super interested. So you, I walked in. Yeah.
I was a kid and I walked in. I've been dead, but yeah. That's another story.
Yeah. So technically is this just passing? Yeah, it is. Yeah.
It is just passing. It is. I get that feeling all the time. Every time,
like I walk by a building that's under construction and you can just see like
emptiness into it, but you can see like the structure. Yeah.
I always get the desire.
And I also watch a lot of YouTube videos where people trespas and they climb up
buildings or they go inside and they explore. Yeah. I dunno.
It just dawned on me as I was watching this. And everyone's like,
he's clearly stealing. I'm like, if you were going to do a burglary, no.
Would you choose an empty home of no, it's already empty,
but there's some people like there's some people that bur that,
that do steal from empty homes, from empty homes. That's not what I'm saying.
I'm not saying that I'm not. Cause I'm gonna already hear you in the comments.
Yeah, man. People can, people still copper and shut the up.
That's not what we're talking about.
Sometimes you just wanna envision where things are gonna be. Right.
You go in the empty, it's just the skeleton of the house. And you're like, okay,
so, wow. This is gonna be the kitchen Uhhuh. This is gonna be okay.
This is a little, the, well, this is gonna be the bathroom. Yeah.
You want to envision where things are without stealing. So yeah, I've done it.
Yeah. Yeah.
I remember I used to have this neighborhood had a super nice car in his garage.
Super nice car.
And I remember people would go inside the garage to look at the car. Really?
That always thought would be like, God you walking into that person. No,
I wouldn't do that. I wouldn't do that either.
But people with someone possession, but people are weird like that. Yeah.
People live there. Yeah. It's like, you know, your bike is parked here. Yeah.
I see people like hovering all over, staring, staring at it intentionally.
Absolutely.
It's just interesting how sometimes people invade other people's like personal
pro property or whatever. Not necessarily maliciously. Yeah. But still stupidly.
But yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. If you have a bike, you know,
people sit on your bike all the time, Uhhuh.
They want to take pictures and selfie and stuff like that. Yeah. I mean,
it's like, yeah, don't do that. And again,
this is not to say that he was there for something nefarious or he wasn't,
this is just like a sidebar. Uh, but let's keep.
Going. Yeah. At two 13,
the first man appears to run out the front door and down the street.
Investigators have not said there is any evidence Arbery burglarized the home
police reports following the shooting. Did not know anything stolen on Arbery.
So let's.
Break down what we saw compared to the law under Georgia law,
a person commits the offense of criminal trespass when he or she knowingly and
without authority enters upon land or premise of another person for an unlawful
purpose, each one of the elements have to be met based on the video.
What purpose did he walk into the house for?
And what was the pur and what was the purpose? Unlawful.
According to the video and the owner of the house,
he didn't take anything and he didn't force his way in.
He just walked around looking. So is it possible he went to steal something?
Yes. Is it possible? He went in to find the magical door of Narnia. Yeah.
The same way.
It's possible that he went in simply because he was curious and wanted to look
around an unconstructed home. Like millions of people do every single day.
Hell. When my house was being built,
I literally walked in on a couple walking through my unconstructed home.
I was slightly taken aback,
but I wasn't surprised because that's kind of what people do. All.
Right. I'll suit it up.
Steve and I are gonna go for a nice walk and get some exercise.
The sun is out.
See how we're gonna go and see how many calories we are can burn.
And we're gonna go over and check out this new neighborhood.
They're building houses. So we're gonna kind of go in and out some of those.
And that's.
A lot of people in building neighborhoods. Yeah. To be honest with you,
I've seen a lot of people do that. Yeah. Yeah. House being built.
I'm not even just to find out it's right or wrong. That's not what I'm saying,
but that's not news. I've seen people do all that is not news to me, bro.
You can go on YouTube in five videos of people going into houses and abandoned
buildings. That's not all the, that's not news to me, but no, I,
I guess the next question becomes,
is it reasonable to suspect that that person's committing a crime and what makes
you suspect that? Would it be different based off the person's race?
Would it be different based off how you perceive men versus women?
Do you know what I'm saying? That's what the question I would ask it would be.
Yeah, it would definitely.
Do you think it's reason about suspect of committing a crime? I mean,
it would be different depending of the perception.
It's all dependent on the perception. Yeah. Listen, look at my face, right? No,
no. Look at my face. I always look like I'm committing a crime. Right?
I feel you, you know what I mean? Yeah.
Like the people I always look and sometimes I'm just explaining myself,
why you so being so aggressive? No, I'm I'm yeah. Proving my point. Yeah. No,
I get you. So yeah. People look a different way.
Yes.
There's also video of someone going into that house at night that some people
think is Arbery. But to my knowledge, that hasn't been confirmed. However,
nothing in those videos that we have shows that he went inside to steal
something. However, it does show, he walked in, looked around and then left.
Maybe he realized was nothing to steal either way.
You can't infer intent based on weak ambiguous, circumstantial evidence.
So based on the facts we have, we can't say he went in for an unlawful purpose.
More evidence may come out. But from what we have,
it doesn't show him taking or stealing anything.
So the unlawful purpose element isn't met now,
how about did he end to upon the land or premise of another person after
receiving prior to such entry notice from the owner rifle,
occupant or upon proper identification and authorized representative of the
owner or rifle occupant that such entry is forbidden.
Long story short did Arbery have noticed that he could not be on that property
much the same way. A lot of concealed carry laws work.
If you carry a gun into establishment that has a no gun policy,
you're not considered trespassing until they tell you to leave.
And you refuse to do so. In the case of Ray, be V state,
the Georgia Supreme court held that notice must be sufficiently explicit.
Notice that app prizes,
people of exactly what property they are forbidden to enter.
Now let's talk citizens arrest under Georgia law.
A private person may arrest an offender.
If the offense is committed in his presence or within his immediate knowledge,
if the of offense is a felony and the offender is escaping or it's tempting to
escape, a private person may arrest him upon reasonable and probable grounds of
suspicion.
There are four elements in this law that must be satisfied to justify citizen's
arrest. First. A private person may arrest an offender.
If the offense is committed in his presence or within his immediate knowledge,
we have limited video of what Arbery was doing inside the house,
but that's all we have.
So if based on these limited videos of what he did in the house and that wasn't
shown him committing a felony,
it stands to reason that no one on the outside of the house saw him commit a
felony on the inside of the house.
Especially considering that the owner said nothing was taken.
If the cameras inside the house didn't show him committing a felony inside the
house,
then you can't say that an offense was committed in their presence or within
immediate knowledge.
When we have video of what happened inside and still can't conclude an offense
was committed.
The second element of citizen's arrest says a private person may arrest an
offender. If the offense is a felony, trespassing in Georgia is a misdemeanor.
Burglary is a felony. As I stated before,
nothing in the video shows that he committed a trespass or burglary.
So the second element isn't met, keep in mind,
you have to meet all of the elements and we already can't meet two of the
elements. So there's no point in even discussing the third one, but I will.
The third element, the offender is escaping or attempting to escape.
Let's say Aubrey got spooked by the neighbor who saw him go inside the house and
decided to run. If he was committing a felony, then yes,
this element would be met because he was leaving the house and the neighbor
would be able to make a citizen's arrest because if Arbery actually committed a
felony and the neighbor saw it or saw Arbery running out of the house with tools
or materials, then he could make that citizen's arrest.
But as I showed you before, based on the information we have at this moment,
there was no felony now on self defense right now, based on the videos we have,
we have yet to establish what law Arbery violated under Georgia law.
If you make a citizen's arrest and you're wrong about that person violating the
law, you think they violated, then you can be charged with false imprisonment.
Ironically, that was one of the first things I learned in law school right now,
based on all the acts we have before us, not facts in the future. But right now,
what law did he break based on the letter of the law?
Not what you feel he broke, but what law?
He broke based on the letter of the law. If you say none, then right now,
based on what we have before us,
you can't say with any certainty that McMichael was justified in blocking the
road and trying to make a citizen's arrest of Arbery while holding a shotgun.
At least not based on the information we have now that could change tomorrow or
next week. But right now you can't say that for a fact,
you can feel he was right, but based on the letter of the law,
you can't say it's a fact it's feeling. There's no question.
That McMichael was the initial confronter and it wasn't justified by law to
confront Arbery then by law, he's the initial aggressor.
So whenever Arbery encountered him,
he had every right to use lethal force to defend his life because McMichael was
holding a gun in his hand while trying to block Arbery's path.
So I am saying based on the evidence at hand that is available to the public,
there was enough evidence to charge the McMichael with something.
And that's why the GDI charged them.
I feel like we have nothing insightful to add. I mean,
there's nothing much to add. I, I would just want to wait for more information.
That's pretty much what he's saying. Yeah. Let's wait for more information.
That's what we've been saying. It's like, I mean, it's sad what we thought,
but yeah. You know, the unfortunate part about this whole thing.
And I think one that I don't like is like,
everyone is always to a conclusion based off of limited evidence, right?
First thing came out. Everyone's like, all right, this is what happened.
Then the second batch came out. Now everybody else was like, actually,
you guys were wrong. This is what happened.
There's no proof to infer that he wasn't jogging.
There's no proof to infer that he did something illegal.
There's no proof to infer that he did anything.
I think the big problem with all this is that we're so polarized and we're so
quick to be like, prove the narrative wrong that we're not being patient.
And we're also guilty of this ourselves. So yeah, when,
when we did the first video, we were like, oh, I'm tired of this. And it's why,
you know, we always get comments. People like you guys are late.
You guys are late to this topic. And the reason we like to be late,
cause we like to have all the information, that's it.
That's why we don't like to jump on topics early when they just come out,
generally speaking. So we feeling like this. We have to wait.
Even the people were like, you see Abba, he wasn't jogging. How do you know?
Maybe he was jogging up to that street and he stopped.
I walk I'm I walked before I jogged. He walked, you saw the house, go into that.
No, get out and start walking. Or do you first? No, he's far away from,
he was far from, he doesn't matter. Maybe he stopped. That's the whole point.
Yeah, that's right. A lot of people do jog, take a walk and then keep Jo.
But we don't know. And to think that you happen to know is ridiculous. Well,
we don't have enough information.
So I think with all of what I'm seeing right now,
it's hard to comment on this stuff. That being said
what remains to be true. And what I'm still believing is that
for cases like this to move for forward, it shouldn't take public outcry.
I don't like the fact that the only reason that this case moved forward cuz was
because everyone got on social media and said something about,
because we saw the video, not because they cause they saw the video. Right? And,
and that's what bothers me.
And then even some of the behavior of the other lawyers, we were like,
this is what it is.
Even though they rec accused themselves and found themselves to be biased.
They also wrote recommendations in favor of the people who shot. Aery I'm like,
if you bias, then why are you trying to bias them with your recommendation? If,
if you recuse yourself, don't put salt in the sauce. Right? Right.
If you don't wanna be in the kitchen, don't play with the pepper,
that's it. So there's still elements to this case that we can,
100% say are off and wrong and that's still indictment on the judicial system
within that area a hundred percent. Yep.
But when it comes to the particulars of this case, I don't take back.
Most of what I said, I don't, there's gonna be more information actually.
Let me rephrase that.
I would've preferred not to comment on it because the fact that it's limited
information, that's what I would've preferred.
But on the elements that we can confirm that are, you know,
the judicial aspect of it, that I'm not a fan of, but again,
we're still operating on limited information.
So all this seems like a giant waste of time.
We should have listened to it saw before. Yeah. Or we said, yo, let's just wait.
But you know, we should have wait, this man's a lawyer.
He's clearly speaking like one it's great to watch.
So if you guys want to hear a really informed opinion on exact particulars of
the law goes into him, honestly, we don't have much to offer you on this topic.
CNN call you on nor <laugh> stupid.
So anyway, let us know what you guys think in the comments.
What do you think about the new updates through the change?
Your opinion and yeah. What do you think about our stance? The idea of like,
Hey, let's just all wait. Cause nobody's right.
The process is going on because they, they know we're watching,
let them do their job. Shout out to co noir. Uh,
let us know how to say your name. Sorry about that, bro. Yeah. Uh,
and second thing, don't forget to subscribe to the Paton.
We have a patron going on. Check that out. We also have a podcast I wear preach.
Check it out. Something else. Nope. That's pretty much it.